well the virus will inevitably of course
put the National Health Service under
severe pressure and today the
government's effectively put British
industry on a war footing as we were
hearing from Matt Hancock earlier asking
them to transform their production lines
in order to produce more ventilators and
tackle the virus so is the Health
Service prepared joining us now is the
chair the British Medical Association
dr. Chand nag Paul thank you very much
being on the program again much
appreciated it's always good to get some
expert advice on the real situation and
we were talking to the health secretary
earlier and he sent out this call to
arms for businesses to produce more
ventilators firms can't make too many if
you make a ventilator we will buy it
clearly the NHS doesn't have enough
ventilators right now yeah so our
starting position unfortunately has been
far worse than many other of our
European nations we have about a quarter
of the critical care beds that Germany
has as an example so it's really
critical it's really important that we
now see transparently what plans the
government has to expand that capacity
that will also of course be in tandem
with trying to slow down the spread of
the infection so that we don't see a
peak that overwhelms the health service
but yes we need to see that transparency
the plans and exactly how we will be
able to support the demands of critical
care on the health service why do we
have so much fewer ventilators these ads
than other countries so the British
Medical Association has been campaigning
or lobbying for us to have the sort of
infrastructure that many other European
nations take for granted it's a result
of a decade of underfunding and now what
therefore we need to do is make some
really decisive decisions on how that
limited resource is used in the best
possible way for those who are going to
need it and that may require and it
should require actually some major
decisions for example on ceasing non
urgent routine care a mass move towards
many more consultations occurring
remotely we need to see the government
implementing and in a
for example GP surgeries to provide
online consultations it's occurring in
some but it's by no means widespread
there's no need in my view for patients
to be going into a hospital clinic now
simply to be given a test result we need
to have clear plans where how patients
can be remotely managed and how the
technology can support that so do you
think the whole GP system as you like
needs to be looked at in the months
ahead well yes and then one of the most
immediate priorities of course is we
don't have enough doctors before the
outbreak we were ten thousand doctors
short so we're very worried and the
doctors that I represent are very
concerned that they don't for example
have adequate protection GPS have paper
masks of a low effectiveness they're
worried that when they're seeing
patients in their clinics at close
proximity they might get infected and if
they do they'll be off work the other
priority for the health service must be
rapid testing of doctors because with
the government's policy of self
isolation for seven days we may see many
health care workers who may not have
covered 19 who may be offered two or
three days recover and yet still be off
work because of the policy if they could
be tested they could come back to work
and I can't emphasize how how serious
the problem is if you've got doctors off
work in a GP surgery with three or four
doctors if two of them are self
isolating that could effectively prevent
the practice running in a normal fashion
you effectively calling for the end of
non urgent NHS care I think that we have
to be responsible we know that we don't
have the facilities for critical care we
need to expand those facilities
hospitals need to now start to vacate
routine facilities and convert them into
intensive care beds and so what does I
think we're talking about we're talking
about routine operations but also if you
have an illness that you know is not
coronavirus or is not potentially
life-threatening that you should just
stay away
effectively yes is the to two ways to
deal with it one yes we need to make
some decisions around all the government
needs to make decisions around stopping
non-urgent services so that we can
target our care to those that are ill
and need immediate attention but also
there are different ways of providing
care as I said we can move to far more
technology enabled remote management of
patients using video telephone links but
but also we need to be targeting and
protecting those who are the most
vulnerable so in terms of social
distancing that we know that those who
have got pre-existing medical conditions
those older patients who would be the
illest if they were to contract the
virus those are the the groups that we
need to be protecting and isolating from
getting infected on that and the health
secretary Earl is saying that they are
looking at asking the over 70s to
effectively south isolate but not yet do
you think that needs to happen now I
think it's important that we protect the
at-risk groups now absolutely if you
were over 70 well I would look at south
isolating I think it's really important
that that not just those that are over
70 those that have got respiratory
illnesses and those that are
immunocompromised
do need to be taking measures and the
government needs to have a policy for
such patients to be protected and what
kind of measures do you mean that means
not not going into crowds not mixing
with others where there may be we know
this circulating infection so be by
isolating you are reducing the risk of
contracting the virus the the other
thing I also must mention because the
British Medical Association represents
retires doctors many of them are asking
questions about how they can perhaps
support the medical workforce after the
announcement two weeks ago we've
received no details it's really
important that we see exactly what is
planned to enable us to have the doctor
and workforce capacity to deal with this
are you confident in the government
approach I think that we need
information now I don't think you know
we've got that information and as I said
earlier you can't just get doctors to
return back to work instantly we need to
understand
how they'll be registered how they'll be
trained exactly what they'll be doing
especially for many retired doctors who
could also be in a risk group they can
provide care but in a remote fashion not
patient-facing so we really need those
answers plans now just finally we spoke
a couple of weeks ago he was sitting in
the same place and I feel that you'll
see much more worried now your your
manner your demeanor is that fair of
course I'm worried I mean I said two
weeks ago that this situation could
change on a daily basis and in fact that
is exactly what has happened we are in a
very different place compared to two
weeks ago when in fact when we met we
had about 20 yards cases that is why I
don't think we have the luxury of time
anymore we need to have clear decisive
plans we need to have a very targeted
approach as I said I represent doctors
they need to be kept healthy they need
to be protected because if we have any
reduction in our workforce we won't be
able to provide the care patients need
are you seeing those clear decisive
plants as I said I think we need them
now we have concerns that we don't have
all of those answers at the mode we need
them ok thank you so much being on the
show and putting your viewpoint across
much appreciated thank you